J'ai désiré être un ange, je
les admire, quelque chose que je ne peux pas monter là-haut un
jour, je vais aussi le faire
pour beaucoup d'autres femmes et
chaque année, nous regardons le
défilé de mode Victoria's Secret et il  J'ai commencé à
regarder les modèles et à comparer
cela à vous-même, puis vous commencez à vous
déprimer, vous commencez à vous battre
comme si, eh bien, mes jambes ne sont pas si longues,
je ne mesure même pas 1,50 mètre comme si personne ne
me laisserait.  marcher sur un podium à moins que nous
commencions à comprendre que tout le monde est
différent
[Musique]
peu importe si vous mesurez cinq pieds,
six pieds, cent livres, 200
livres si vous avez 20 ou 60 ans, vous êtes
belle et le  histoire, les cicatrices, tu
sais, les choses qui font la différence sont ce qui
est beau chez toi. J'ai hâte
de voir tout le monde se sentir belle,
sortir et tuer
[Musique]